buenas noches aquí steve y ahora puedo
hablar en español porque uno de mis
oyentes me ha pedido de hacerlo porque
hace mucho tiempo que no hablo en
español y es porque no vamos español
hace como dos años que casi nunca hablo
español
desde el tiempo que he visitado méxico
gméxico con mi esposa hace dos años
estoy estudiando ruso reino coreano
y otros idiomas y es un gran lástima
porque me gusta muchísimo hablar español
me gusta muchísimo tener contacto con
la gente que habla español en los países
de lengua lengua española
y es un lástima también que estudiando
muchos idiomas muchos idiomas es
imposible
no nos puede sacar el tiempo a cada uno
de esos idiomas que yo quería hacer
porque me gusta muchísimo no solamente
español francés y chino
hace hace
un rato hablando en inglés
sobre el tema de el dominio de su mismo
he dicho que bueno en la vida hay muchas
cosas que nosotros no podemos controlar
puede ser la situación económica la
situación política el tiempo
yo juego al golf yo no puedo controlar
la dirección d
de gente
bueno pero hay cosas que podemos
controlar
si podemos consagrar más bueno
preocuparse de cosas que podemos
controlar este nos da más satisfacción
en el aprendizaje de idiomas hay tres
cosas en ser esenciales primera cosa es
la actitud hacia
el aprendizaje hacia el idioma hacia su
mismo
ay qué
tener el gusto de aprender
el que el idioma
nos gusta
que tenemos confianza todas esas cosas
de actitud son muy muy importantes y son
cosas que podemos controlar si estamos
estudiando un idioma que no nos gusta
bueno hay que cambiar de idioma o o bien
de forzarse un poco y poco a poco se va
a gustar del yom va del idioma no
entonces y también esta cosa de
confianza no hay que tener miedo no hay
que hay que hay que darse hay que darse
cuenta de que el hecho que estás capaz
de hablar
tan mal que sea en un otro idioma ya es
un éxito es algo estupendo que porque la
mayoría de la gente alrededor de ti no
son capaces de hacerlo bueno confianza
en el gusto
y bueno es esa actitud positiva actitud
positiva es una cosa que podemos
controlar la segunda cosa
de pasar el tiempo consagrar el tiempo
necesario para tener éxito porque
aprender idiomas bueno es necesita
previsto aprender historia cada día 13
minutos
a 30 minutos una hora y durante meses
meses puede ser seis meses un año pero
hay que continuar y este también es una
cosa de nuestra determinación son cosas
que podemos controlar y la tercera cosa
es de estar atento y atento a lo que
pasa en el idioma lo que ocurre en el
idioma este también es una cuestión de
concentración de voluntad es eso es una
cosa que nosotros podemos controlar
entonces
en la vida hay tantas cosas que podemos
hacer hay tantas cosas sobre él
los cuales podemos preocupar no podemos
preocuparnos de la situación en el medio
oriente clima económica alopecia pero no
podemos controlar
e influenciar la evolución de esas cosas
pero el aprendizaje de idiomas es una
cosa que podemos controlar es una cosa
que nos da mucha satisfacción por
ejemplo en el mes de septiembre yo voy
con mi esposa vamos a viajar en francia
y los dos hablamos francés es siempre
mucho más agradable viajar en un país
donde podemos comunicarnos con la gente
leer
los periódicos entender lo que la gente
está diciendo no por eso que el
aprendizaje de idiomas
no solo es una cosa
que podemos controlar entonces que dan
mucha satisfacción pero es también una
cosa que
nos da mucho mucha riqueza no
bueno yo creo que porque hace mucho
tiempo que no hablo español muchos
errores pero bueno es por mi amigo que
en su comentario a la última vídeo ha
dicho por favor haga un vídeo